Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson pushed a conspiracy
theory on Carrie Lake that was so crazy that
Kerry Lake almost didn't go for it, but she
still kind of did. There's really no conspiracy
theory. Too insane for Kerry Lake. Remember that
Kerry Lake is running for governor in Arizona.
She I have my fingers crossed. She seems
to be going in the direction of losing. And
we'll look at the latest numbers in a moment.
Tucker Carlson pushes the conspiracy theory
that her opponent, Katie Hobbs. Wasn't worried
about the election because Katie Hobbs is running
the election and knew that she was going
to steal it. And Kerry Lake recognizes she
can't just come out and say, you know, Tucker,
that's exactly what it is. But she basically
says that Tucker isn't wrong. Check this out.
Speaker 6: So your opponent is the secretary
of state. She didn't campaign much, and she
didn't seem like she needed to campaign a
lot. She never debated you. And some are
smirking online that well, of course,
she was always confident in her victory. What's
your view of that very common take on the race?
Speaker 3: You're trying to get me to say
something that might get me in trouble?
Speaker 1: No, no, it's just. I've read 50 people
say that, folks. 50 read it. Commenters said it.
And that's why Tucker is bringing it up.
Speaker 3: That that means people are so
distrustful. What they're insinuating
is that she knew she could sit back,
hide in the basement, do nothing.
Speaker 1: That's exactly what Tucker is saying.
Speaker 3: When? Due to cheating, that's what
they're insinuating. And I understand why
they would insinuate that, because we've
had such terrible elections. They're run
poorly. They're ripe with fraud. So your opponent.
Speaker 1: This is you know, it almost seems like
Kerry Lake is going to hesitate before jumping
in on that one because it could, quote, get her
in trouble. But then actually she does go for it.
And he explains he he says what he's thinking. And
she says the entire conspiracy theory, unless she
follows it with. But I don't believe that that's
true. It's very clear that she's also accepting
the very same conspiracy theory and understand
the implication. Tucker read 50 people said it.
So it must be true. That's now what the guy who
says you can't trust anything, you read anywhere.
Nobody. The media won't tell you the truth. Social
media is filled with lies. Well, Tucker, read
that. 50 people wrote this on the Internet.
Could have been Twitter. Could have been read it.
Who knows? And so it must be true. So let's look
at the latest numbers right now. Right now, with
93% of the vote in. Katie Hobbs is leading by one
point over Kerry Lake, which is about 26,000
votes. The analysis I've read are that the
remaining ballots are unlikely to go so much in
Kerry Lake's favor that they would put her ahead
until it's over. We wait and see. Make sure
you're following us on Instagram at David
Pakman show and you can follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman. Quick break and right back.